jour 2 de la mission européenne de
pauline marois la première ministre du
québec est à monaco où elle va
participer de même conférence
internationale sur la gouvernance les
avants elle va rencontrer le ministre
des affaires étrangères de la france
laurent fabius st sébastien bovet suis
la première ministre pauline marois est
arrivé dans la principauté de monaco qui
compte un peu moins de quarante mille
habitants et où à chaque coin de rue on
sent que la principauté respire la
richesse elle rencontrera en ce moment
rires de monaco le ministre des affaires
étrangères laurent fabius pour parler
des échanges commerciaux entre la france
et le québec
elle parlera d'électrification des
transports de sa politique économique
qui vise la création d'emplois au québec
mais le point central des discussions
sera probablement l'accord de libre
échange entre le canada et la france
certains producteurs laitiers du québec
ont des réticences face à cet accord de
libre-échange madame marois fera aussi
par de la protection que les produits
culturels québécois doivent avoir sur le
marché québécois ce qui est prévu
d'accord par l'accord de libre échange
canada europe pour lequel il ya une
entente de principe entre l'union
européenne et le canada
madame marois part à monsieur fabius qui
connaît bien le québec il a été premier
ministre de la france au milieu des
années 80 il a tenu deux conférences
alternée des premiers ministres avec
rené lévesque
à l'époque il avait reçu l'ordre
national du québec et sa dernière visite
au québec remonte à juin 2005
c'est le premier entretien formel entre
pauline marois et monsieur fabius
mais il semble qu'ils ont pris l'avion
ensemble pour partir de paris et venir
jusqu'à nice puis par la suite monaco
donc la conversation a dû commencer bien
avant cette première rencontre formelle
c'est parce qu'à beauvais radio-canada
monaco